New York city mayor Eric Adams who
basically is a communist is now calling
and again New York is basically a
sanctuary State and New York City is a
sanctuary City meaning if you come there
they will take care of you you will get
Services you will get a phone they will
figure out housing for you well it's not
just that they want to find public
housing for you this one is wild if you
think that these people are not
Communists every now and again they
actually say the part that your own
private property will not be yours this
is absolutely wild and again was this
covered on CNN or MSNBC here is New York
city mayor Eric Adams calling on New
Yorkers to house illegal aliens in their
private residences play the videotape
is with discipline and we're executing
on it it is my vision uh to take the
next step to this to go to the faith
base the locales and then move to uh
private residence of their residents who
are suffering right now because of
economic challenges they have spare
rooms they have locales and if we can
find a way to get over the 30-day Rule
and other rules that government has in
in this place we can take that 4.2
billion dollars 4.3 it may be now that
we potentially have to spend and we can
put it back into pockets of everyday New
Yorkers everyday houses of worship
instead of putting in the pockets of
Corporations and some of those
corporations come from outside our city
these people should be studied they
should be studied by sociologists and
scientists spiritual leaders
everything they do is wrong and
backwards and you might go but he thinks
he's doing the right thing but the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
what he is saying there is for some of
these people that are supposed to be
kicked out after 30 days okay we'll try
the faith-based thing we'll set them up
in churches and synagogues and things
like that for a little bit but uh you
know we're going to keep letting them in
uh you've got a room over there how many
people you think Eric Adams is going to
have living in the mayor's residence
with him
you think any of those guys even even
the sunglass guy with those cool shades
you don't think he would maybe get in
there this is what they are going to do
do not think that they will not take
this to the craziest the nth degree of
lunacy because they will take it there
they are telling you they will take it
there your private residence why is your
private residence yours why is your
property yours you've got to help those
people my parents still live in New York
and I want to be very clear Mom and Dad
if you're watching the show today if my
childhood bedroom ever becomes a center
for illegal immigrants
I'm not going to be able to visit you at
the old age home one day that's we're
just putting it out there I cannot do it
I cannot do it I've got my old posters
are still in there from like 1992 and
that's the way it's going to be
[Music]